foreign
[Music]
here we go it's another episode uh
uh I will be in Tucson Arizona uh June
17th crystalia.com and I will be in
Pueblo Colorado Colorado Springs uh and
I got some dates in Las Vegas and the
dope push me tours coming to Charlotte
North Carolina Knoxville a bunch of
different dates coming up get your
tickets while they last
uh Montreal is about to sell out
Hamilton is sold out Pittsburgh
Cleveland Detroit Orlando I'm not sure
how many are I don't know if any of
these are sold out I don't think they
are they're bigger places but um anyway
go to chrisley.com to come see me the
Don't Push Me Tour and without further
Ado this is the next episode of
congratulations
[Music]
um so that's what's up yeah and uh you
know
I don't know dude it's uh it's a good
it's a good day except for the fact that
it's gloomy again and I know you don't
want to keep you don't come to me for
the weather I know you come with me for
the you come to me for the hard-hitting
facts I brought this uh lint roller to
my podcast Studio because I thought
sometimes I have lint on it but um I
don't have lint on it whatever that's
boring but um yeah it's gloomy and you
don't call me for the weather report but
also sometimes you need the weather
report here's the deal man Los Angeles
was fired on all cylinders almost threw
up in my mouth firing on all cylinders
okay it really was and then covet
happened and then it kind of all went to
shind all right
um
so three four years later it's okay but
here's the deal one of the main it's
expensive is Ash to live in uh Los
Angeles okay
the the best part was always the weather
and now the weather just goes like this
no yeah you know what it actually does
suck there and I'm not trying to bad
mouth La I'm in La dude I'm in L.A I'm
in LA because I want to be I'm not one
of those people that's like Dude it
sucks here or there or wherever I live
and and then it doesn't suck it's harder
but also sup with the weather we need
the weather to get
the it's the clouds dude and it's all
the time and it's cold and it's rainy I
can't get my car washed you know and I
know that every time I complain about
something people who don't get the humor
are in the comments by the way leave a
comment
And subscribe make sure you're
subscribed to uh super good Studios
um I know that people are like all right
guy you know there's real problems in
the world I know but also clouds hey
clouds go away dude
um
and it's just gloomy as as all get out
and I don't like it and whenever I wake
up I open my eyes and I look out the
window and I see clouds and then I go
like this isn't that amazing and it
bothers me because I want it to be sunny
I only like Sunny that's it I like it to
be sunny and do I like it when people
say they like the rain no because you
don't really like the rain right you
like to be what inside inside when it's
raining out right it's like I love the
sound of the rain and the get a sound
machine
you're not Brandon Frazier screaming
outside in School ties in the rain right
you're being you're being what we are we
have come to known as a liar okay
you don't like the ring get you all wet
sin convene
um
but anyway it's like we're all just
chilling and then we got Al Pacino
nutting all up in his girl right
82 89 whatever how old he is doesn't
matter it doesn't matter how old you are
once you get past
75.
right 73 Maybe 74.
you're done you're all good right you
better have some seriously comfortable
pants and shoes and that's it really
because but Al Pacino goes like this oh
no I'm not done
right that's what he did oh oh no no no
I'll keep nothing
huh
another kid how many kids does Al Pacino
have
uh four kids well he's about to have
five I thought to have four that's the
fourth one he's about to have the fourth
one
with 29 year old woman
whatever you know she's in it for
that's the Al Pacino baby right oh yeah
um
and so he all got it all up in her and
I'm not trying to be crass right but he
got up in them guts and then
um and then he's gonna have a baby come
out you know nine months later baby's
gonna come out Bear's gonna be like oh
yeah oh boy and the dead now but she
knows of course he's not gonna be there
but if he was he'd be like oh yeah
that's a boy
or it's a girl all right
and uh good thing I nodded oh good thing
I'm nutted
um
good thing I didn't put a sheet over it
oh boy
all right
um so
anyway just 80 [__] hundred however
old he is 80 17. and he just that's it
dude
God and also what's the deal with Al
Pacino doing it like people are always
like hey Al Pacino is just like there
they mix up Al Pacino and Robert De Niro
you know
and then Al Pacino and then Robert De
Niro he did it he's gonna have a kid
again right
oh yeah oh yeah
and then he goes
all right
and then I'll put you know what he did
what oh boy
hello come over oh yeah
now what
[Laughter]
all right
that's how that's how that's how De Niro
just gets all up in them guts
all right
[Laughter]
that's how he straight up splurts just
all right
all right I'm all done
oh yeah and then and then uh they are
gonna have kid dude they're gonna those
kids are gonna grow up they're gonna
meet each other one day and they're just
gonna be like
yeah you know I know
all right the kids can be like all right
I just uh he's 83 years old and Robert
De Niro is
oh wow Al Pacino asked Alf a girlfriend
Noor alfala to take DNA test or because
I know I'm not the only one you've been
you know I know I'm the only one right
um
uh yeah so I don't know if you're 80
something though and you it actually I
will say this dude
um
if you're
you thought he could no longer have
children and then that chick was like
let's see what's up though if you're 80
something and you're wearing condoms oh
here's the deal it's very
um
it's very
responsible to wear condoms if you're
over 80. I mean you know we know they
don't because they're like [__] it I'm
gonna be dead and I wanna
and I want to be really feeling all that
stuff right that's what that's what old
dudes think probably I don't know 80 but
they're probably like yeah like that's
where they say like herpes and like all
of the crazy STDs are rampant in like
retirement communities because like why
would they be cheating right
because they want to feel all that
right they want to literally feel all
that
and have it just be like isn't that
amazing you know what I mean and um
and so
but also it's very irresponsible right
because you don't want to have a kid
that grows up without a father right I
don't I wouldn't do that because
you know
now that I know what it's like to be a
father
there's just zero way I mean I gotta be
around I started working out again like
harder because I want to be able to like
keep fit for my children and that's
straight up you know now I don't say
this a lot but that's on God you know
and don't believe in God I don't even
know right but like that's on God right
so
yeah I can't imagine just straight up
being 82 because when that baby comes
out you're gonna want to have that oh I
want to be here I would go I would Tail
Spin dude
I would just have a tailspin I would
spin out that that's my son or daughter
now isn't going to be able to and I just
gotta I got a few more oh Yeahs left in
me and that's it
and she's gonna have to watch you know
she's gonna have to grow up and just
know me from uh
the [__] Dog Day Afternoon movie
that's your dad really yep
was he four six
you look so short in that movie but he
maybe he is I don't know I met him once
I met Al Pacino once and he was awesome
he walked in the room and he was just
like hi
um and I was like eh Pacino
um
so yeah dude I don't know and the Nero
just was
denier how old is De Niro
79 okay so yeah I guess you could be
around for another 20 years but still
I mean 79 89.99 I mean by the time
you're 85 you're just
oh dude I can't even imagine being 85.
even now I'm like my patients are being
worked all the time right dude someone
was in line the other day I went to this
place
because I ate good chicken from it and I
and I go like this the next day I like
you know what dude I want that chicken
again
so I go and I park in the 15 minute slot
because I'm just gonna go pick up the
chicken and come back
and the 15 minute slots really easy to
get to so I parked there and I go wait
in line for the chicken the line 25
minutes so already I'm like okay they're
working my last nerve I am next now and
the people in front of me is two women
and the guy
and it they did the thing where like
they're in the line and I'm waiting and
uh
and then other people their friends were
coming up and saying [__] and I'm like
are you all ordering for them like let's
go I need to know what I'm getting into
what kind of line I'm getting into right
but I'm 43 so I'm like
not you know my point is like my pages
are already worth then period I'm at
Point at at jump my patients are already
like all right what's going on here
though hold on right no matter what's
about to happen I uh right so the people
are in front of me and and and the line
now here's why I tell you the lines 25
minutes not even because I you know I'm
not even trying to tell you that like
that's a long time for me I'm trying to
tell you
the lights 25 minutes when you get there
that's a wrap you go I want this I want
this I want this I want this thank you
here's my car have it out I got my card
Bing there we go boom
these people walk up uh this [__]
already
no
have
already read it have yourself a read
already before you get up there also the
there's like nine things on the thing
and you're just getting a chicken right
it's a chicken place
you can get a salad with chicken on it
you get a chicken I don't even look at
the thing you get a here's what I know
you can get a salad with chicken on it a
chicken sandwich or or a chicken
that's what you can get
and even if you don't look at the sign
know yourself
you know what you like even if
you want
chicken parmesan which they're probably
not gonna have because it's just a place
you walk up and get some chicken from
you go up you say I got chicken parmesan
they say no and you go like this all
right
salad with the chicken on it or just
chicken
walk up and be like do you have steak no
it's a chicken place okay
these people are like do I now does it
cut now does the if I get it does it
have the what
read it
and do the things come with the thing
with the this is the [__] they're doing
okay so and this is the worst part the
lady
who's doing it turns around and does
that jokey all right sorry you know I I
know but I'm sorry I should
and the other lady laughs hard at it and
I'm just like hey
you know what dude
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
Mark Shapiro should be in jail
huh
I'm like nah dude
get it going
don't be all joking turn around yo I'm
actually really sorry I didn't know it
was gonna take a song I really should
have been prepared I go like this that's
all good right
thank you for understanding my plight
but I went in there dude I swear to God
she did it and just to make a point dude
I time myself just to make a point I go
I want this this I don't dude I ordered
five things for everybody at home
this this and this and this and this is
that it yup put the [__] card in took
it out sign the thing miles done dude
that was it
then it took another 25 minutes from 50
minutes dude it's a new place but get
your [__] together right
50 minutes
ah and they had and also in the window
it's one of those places that shows the
chickens turning which I don't I sorry I
don't want to see it
first of all second of all they had 900
chickens
cut it up
cut it up serve it
so anyway my point is when I'm 82 holy
[__]
that's what I kind of get when you're 82
I get the impetus to not use condoms
because you're like I waited so long for
I got no time left and I waited 50
minutes for [__] chicken I'm not
wearing a rubber
I needed to make the most of this while
I'm alive and I hope my son or daughter
whoever comes out I hope they get it
because if they don't they will by the
time they're 80.
oh I get it they go
um
so yeah
dude I was in the uh
so my wife is the default parent right
which she I don't know what that is but
I'm assuming it means that
I don't even know if I let me hold on
let me look up what a [__] default
parent is
default
parent she she's like always home or
something a diva parent typically the
one who's first in line when it comes to
caring for children Charlie to talk to
us yeah well okay I guess
but I don't really agree with this
because it all depends on
what the [__] happens
you know William yeah he's real young
really all he does is
drink that milk you know what I mean
it's not coming from me so yeah she's
the default parent but if cow slips and
falls
and Bonks his head he runs and hugs me
he might run and hug her too
but
we know what it means default parent
okay but so she's I guess I don't like
that term because I think
you know
we're at we're at Nintendo World and
Calvin wants to jump on my shoulders
right so who's the default parent there
okay
but my anyway so she says she's the
default parent because this woman
uh amber Thornton created a term
they'd be creating terms man I'll tell
you that much and um
so
my wife is doing a lot of the
uh you know hey William drink this
which is an all-time it's on all con
it's a get it that's tough I I can't
imagine having a part of my body that
like another being had to had to like
depend on to live I would I mean I would
just be like I can't even win line for
[__] chicken you know
so
the dogs I guess on the lower level of
my house on the bottom level the lowest
level I'll say
lower sounds like I have two levels I
have more than I have three left I'm not
even okay but it's the truth
my dogs just threw the [__] up two of
them like like they went there to do it
like they were like they're in like
Ibiza and it's [__] 3am and I say
Ibiza
so my dogs went down to Ibiza and just
go a bit and then ran back up
stunk to how I have and my wife takes
some paper towels and just
puts them on there like didn't wipe it
up she just put it on to where you throw
it down and then you see the the liquid
to throw up just kind of over the towel
like that disgusting [__] we're like oh
wow there's actually a lot more than I
thought
so it's there for a day
okay and by the way I'm with my wife on
this I I don't I'm not calling her out I
think that's amazing dude keep that [__]
there till you till you know what till
you wanna pick it up I don't give a [__]
I walk by it like three times I don't
care it's covered we good
okay
so it's there for a day I think I might
have been there for two days I have no
[__] idea not more than two days but
there's dog throw up on my lowest level
and the [__] towels are over it with
the you know
with the with the disgusting you could
see it was Beijing
so my wife I'm I'm breezing past it for
a day and a half okay my wife says hey
the doctor's coming
because we gotta test we gotta see if
Calvin's a little bit under the weather
um and I'm like this is unnecessary he's
got the sniffles like it's fine but
whatever if it's RSV which is a bad
thing for a very very young child to get
then he has it then he could give it to
William and then that's bad right
so the doctor comes to test him it's
fine she puts the swab up his nose but
before that
uh she says hey can you go clean up the
the throw up
because
the doctor's coming
and I was like
yeah even though I don't want to get
it's all good right because I guess I
mean Dr C throw up all the time right
they're doctors but she cheated as a
woman my my wife doesn't want another
woman because she has a dirty house and
I get that
so in a way it's like you do it but also
I'll do it right because you're the
default parent you gotta feed William so
I go down there
I go I don't I don't go I go with an
extra little piece of bounty [__] I go
down I go to wipe it up dude hey
oh it was only a little throw up stop
the cap
dude it was a mountain
of hard
used to be gelatinous brown something
okay hey and it didn't smell bad stop
the cow
dude I couldn't he was looking at the
cartoons
the bad smell and it went like this
like with the smoke
and I go and I say I go I look at my
little paper towel and I said oh babe
it's way worse than I thought I can't I
got him I'm gonna take dish towels I'm
gonna get dish towels [__] it
yeah cause I could just do this with a
FL a few Kleenex
so I got dish towels I take the dish
towels and in a way I'm bringing the
dish towels downstairs and I'm like I
hope it cleans it up but in a way I'm
like oh it just kind of ruins the dish
towels
right
because it should have been done already
she she just laid the [__] on there
which I'm with her and I get it
and I would have done the same thing but
still ah and away
because I'm a piece of [__] I'm like I
hope this ruins your [__] dish towels
and I hope I got the good ones I don't
even know what the good ones are I hope
these are the ones you like I hope
they're staying beige all the time
though forever
so
I go and I got also here's the thing I
look under the sink like what can I
clean this with because I need it d
grimer
I don't even know what I picked I picked
something and it this is what my
cleaning ladies do dude they [__]
take bottles of [__] when they empty out
they fill it with other [__] and put
tape over it and then write a new thing
they just like write what it's for
kitchen so I'm like oh dude what is this
[__]
I have no idea it's not the kitchen but
still I'm like look kitchen the spray
that you're using the kitchen some it's
got to be some dope [__] because it's
what it's food it's got to get the real
Grime the Degreaser you got to get the
[__] you got to get the [__] inside
the oven
so
I take it spray it great it worked dish
towel scooped it up amazing
isn't that amazing so I go to take God
damn dude this is just great
on our second level
on our mid-level we have two baskets now
are they big enough of course not why
because they need to look good and I'm
like function over form or function over
Beauty whatever the [__]
uh
uh but she's like yeah but the little
baskets are cute and I'm like yeah but
what are they for she's like clothes but
I'm like yeah but that's one sweater for
me right so that's amazing right
isn't that amazing so there's two of
them she says this one this is a month
ago this one is for dirty clothes and
this other one is for anything we need
to bring upstairs now they're both too
small so I'm like the [__] we need to
bring upstairs cute tips
two weeks ago we had a conversation
where I say you know what that basket
for our clothes is too small it's about
one sweat one and a half sweater worth
my wife says yeah
so I'm like all right in my head now
I went beyond the conversation which we
do sometimes I I'ma put the dirty
clothes in both the baskets right [__]
it
I didn't even remember I did this so
what I did was
took
the
dishcloths threw them in
one of the baskets I didn't know which
one but it didn't matter because they're
all for clothes now and they both had
clothes in them so I was like my wife's
on board with my plan that I made up in
my head
now
about 10 minutes before this podcast
starts my wife says
what the [__] my wife basically is just
looking down at the [__]
basket and I say huh and she said are
you kidding me you did this
and I'm like the right thing is this a
joke I did what you asked and I put the
[__] thing away in the baskets and
she said you ruined my new clothes and I
said huh and she said I put my new
clothes in the basket to bring upstairs
basket and you put these dish towels
full of throw up in that basket and I
said yeah because I want to wash it he
said you can't put all these chunks to
throw up in the thing and you're gonna
[__] up my new clothes I said new
clothes why are you washing your new
clothes she says I'm not just to bring
upstairs basket so I'm like what
too many rules I thought I did the right
thing so here's my question to you guys
she said go on your podcast and ask
these [__] she didn't say
[__] that's me but in the
comments is it okay to put taking
disregarding the basket I put in the
wrong basket I guess okay but
disregarding that is it okay to put
uh towels you took clean throw up in
and put it in the regular hamper
is that okay yes or no because she says
no
and I say you're gonna watch the whole
[__] thing anyway
I didn't really [__]
how about that
I didn't run [__]
so I'm just like
it's not a problem
um
but yeah you'll be doing that kind of
[__] too right just getting by as a
[__] husband or a boyfriend or a man
that lives with a woman you're just
you're just beginning by right how did
you gay guys do it
because guys don't want to do [__] two
gay guys are just like ah
I'll get to it you know
guys but I don't think that's the
straight male thing right
can you do the thing like do gay guys
are they like can you do you mind this
or like Jesus one of the best things
about being gay is you probably don't
have to do any chores
you know you're just honestly
[__] right
it's Pride so that's kind of it it's
Pride uh in uh everywhere I guess pride
month is every three months I think and
I I feel like maybe I feel this
honestly because I just I live in LA and
it's pretty [__] gay here and that's
fine I love it I think I think all dudes
should [__] dudes straight up
I wish I could do it but it's like you
know bungee jumping for me I just kind
of I don't want to you know
um
but if I did I would do it dude like you
know
I would do it and I would do it a lot
man like
I I I I think all men should should
absolutely [__] other men so if you're
thinking about it get into that but like
um
it's so uh it's very Pride right now and
I was at dinner with my wife and like we
tried to drive a [__] home and
everything was blocked off and there's
not even a parade happening right now
right or is I don't even know I I think
honestly like more than five gay guys
walking around is a parade because
they're just so parady you know you know
they don't just walk they like do it
like that
so I got out of my car to go to dinner
and a dude in a speedo walked by just
like super gay and that's all good I
think most guys should do that straight
or gay
but I here's my problem with the whole
thing
okay
is that we got back in the car after
dinner went home and everything was
blocked off I couldn't drive my regular
route I had to keep making u-turns just
because guys [__] other guys and it's
like that makes no sense
I want to go you know where I want to go
that way but I can't because guys [__]
other guys
do it
[__] other guys like I said I think all
guys should [__] other guys but I want
to go the roots I go
like if I was gay I swear to God I'd be
like ah pride month it is so it's can I
just [__] guys in peace dude I gotta be
all I gotta be all open in my window
hollering out about it
you know let me just suck some you know
let me just suck quietly
did you like that yeah all right cool
just it's fine if you tell people but
just don't be all like singing about it
you know
i i i i and then I was like driving past
a trash can and it said don't Litter
glitter and it was like
Ah that's litter though right
what's the most number oneiest thing
that's litter glitter Glitters
everywhere always
hey look down you got glitter on you
because some [__] wore glitter in
[__] 2007.
right that you walk by that [__] doesn't
go away
um so I can't drive certain places and
it's super gay and that's all good
um
I don't even think it should be gay to
[__] guys I think it should be straight
into guys
um yeah I'm it's like
ah
some days I wish I was a minority so I
could just be like no months for me dude
that whole year is gay as [__]
you know
um that's why if white men which they
will become the minority and and that
because it'll happen we need a white
appreciation day or month right it'll
happen eventually at some point some
white guy will want that in the lobby
for it and then they'll get a massive
following and then maybe it'll happen
bro count me the [__] out I don't want a
month I don't want a day I don't want an
hour you know what we could have a
second hey it's white second when ah
[__] we missed it
oh that's okay don't matter would you
get me for white second
would you get me for white second oh I
got you a [__] um
what my wife got a [__] record player
you know that's the whitest [__]
thing you can get now by the way as a
record player you know what I'm talking
about she got a what a record player
she's never gonna use because she
thought some [__] records looked cool
I love her [__] I love her so much I
love that she did that but it is a white
woman move
you know
um so yeah
I'm like I'm white as [__] though you
know
uh uh so what about the throw up towels
leave signed off in the comments
coming to Tucson soon I'll be in Tucson
so I can get your tickets and I'll be in
Nashville soon get your tickets speaking
of white I saw um chrisley.com I saw um
a video the other day or no no I'm sorry
I took a video the other day
and I didn't do anything I think I
actually deleted it but
um if not I'll show it I'll show it up
here but um
I was driving home
and there was traffic
well I almost threw up a month and
um
the car in front in front of me
first
of all
it was a Scion you know so already go
[__] yourself and it was the boxy one
okay like there's two types of Scions
bad and worse boxy
whoever made a boxy car
there should be an island for those guys
oh yeah yeah oh you made a boxy car yeah
it's a box of car Island
so
yeah we gotta be here because we made a
boxy car it sucks right yeah it's not
aerodynamic and why would you do it
right right
um
there's guys who made Scions certain
Scions and PT Cruisers
um
and on the back of it on the
on the top of the windshield it said
dude
this is so annoying it said stop White
supremacists
hey
yeah
you know
hey
yeah
uh-huh
who the [__]
wants
white supremacy and even white
supremacists are like
well we're not white supremacists per se
it's just that we don't think races
should mix
there's nobody that would be like
yeah dude
I mean the clan
but where are they you know what I'm
saying
even
so it's like they're in the it says stop
white supremacy also also
you're on Laurel Canyon
you're not where the white supremacy is
hey you're a bad salesman
hey guy location location
it bothered me so much because of course
I should have got a bumper sticker that
behind my side said yeah [__] of
course so you drive by and you see his
and you see mine he goes yeah no he's
right obviously
hey stop heads exploding too hey no more
beheadings huh nobody [__] agrees
with that [__] anyway except for like
nine people so here's the deal
you're
other people be like ah it's Brave bro
that's the least Brave thing you could
[__] possibly do
you know what the most Brave thing you
could do
is get a [__] white supremacy
I would say white supremacy on your
[__] car
have it say hey sup Nazis
you can't
you're just good you're in your Echo
chamber the bare minimum is the worst
thing you can do
you change your car to Twitter
people who do these things you put a
bumper sticker the Twitter's the new
bumper sticker you're doing
the least you can do
and people are saying you're brave you
think you're brave you're a loser
people go I tweeted dude that's Brave I
was Brave for saying that
the least
you suck
go knock on the door for [__] sake ah
but send
return enter
it's just stop white supremacy
foreign
the whole I'm brave for doing not only
the least thing you could possibly do
but also the thing that everybody agrees
with why do people think they're brave
for doing the thing that everyone agrees
with
it's insane dude
oh you're so brave for coming out and
saying that [__] Jesus was a nice guy
you're so brave for coming out and
saying that Backstreet Boys had some
hits
I'm doing the positive of the negative
usually it's negative stuff right
but it's just like dude relax
and I'm sick of [__] Apple
don't make this [__] yet bro let me tell
you something right now I had it with
this [__] Apple hey hey via hey dork ass
[__] that are gonna wear the VR
headset for a day
this is going to be such remember I said
this dude that's kristalia so you know
who said it the [__] headset VR [__]
now I'm not talking about chips in your
brain I'm not talking about chips in
your eyes or you know a wristband that
displays some I'm talking about headset
dude that's gonna be something that we
look back on 30 years after headsets and
we're gonna be like wow what a bunch of
[__] idiots we were back then dude
people don't want to wear headsets okay
even the people that say that's not true
yeah it is you don't want to wear that
[__] you just think you do because
you're you think it sounds cool you
think it seems cool the second you put
that clunk Master 3000 on dude the
second you put that [__] loaf of
bread over your eyes and you're like
it's kind of hard to breathe dude you're
gonna how the most you wear it the 80 of
the time you wear it is going to be the
now that I should because I paid for it
program for the [__] I should really get
my and you'll be wearing like I just
want to look at my phone and watch my
[__] Samsung
well oh dude so what now you get to you
got this clunk Master 3000 on your
[__] head okay you ever put a
football helmet on
first of all
no unless I play football
second of all if you did you go oh wow
it's hot in there
you got the clunk Master 3000 on right
for what
so you could do what look at pictures of
your kids for what
play a video game
for what
to be on Reddit for what
to check your DMs
for what
to Pro what for what
what do you need a VR headset for what
do you
a branch manager at Wells Fargo need to
save up your racks to get a clunk Master
3000 on your head
and have it fog up from your nose breath
what do you need that for
I'm telling you it's going to be such a
flash in the pan thing
talk to me when we can do that Minority
Report [__] right
that's porn
Minority Report
you're in you're in it you're in the
you're in the box now you're just
a minority were porn
um
yeah dude I'm an idiot but whatever man
this is why you listen
the Apple event and [__] everyone looks
like such a doofus with those things on
too the all the all the pictures of the
doofuses with the [__] you know they
got like an Asian guy and a black woman
and then like a a white guy and then
like a you know they got all the sorts
of doofuses just different colored
doofuses just sitting with the [__]
doofus clunk Master Three
the doofus clunk Master Bread Box 3000
so you can
check tweets you dork
dude and people oh oh you saw the thing
oh yeah the new guy is not even Steve
Jobs like who the [__] is this guy could
be just Ralph from a grocery store yeah
get him in you don't even know who he is
anymore oh
[__] clunk Master Bread Box 3000
it's not I don't they trick us with this
technology [__] they really do be doing
that man they really do be doing that
we went to [__] they got us dude they
got us we went to Nintendo World they
got us
we went to Nintendo World or whatever
the hell it's called Super Mario
Brothers land whatever that I don't even
know what it's called Nintendo World I
think Nintendo Land I don't know what it
is
Calvin wanted to go my wife dropped
dropped the she did the Inception right
to him before I woke up she got up with
the baby walked down Calvin walked down
my wife dropped the Inception thought
into his head and then he came up into
my bed and he said dad go to the
Nintendo World and I was like how am I
gonna say no uh buddy I'll be down a
little bit went back downstairs sat on
the couch came downstairs
and my wife said to Calvin Calvin tell
Dad what you said to me and he said I
really want to go and I go I'm [__]
okay
but when we do it we're doing it all
we're going in Nintendo World we're
doing it all
get the tickets where we can do it all
she got the tickets she couldn't even we
couldn't even get the VIP tickets
because they were sold out which I don't
even know what that means it's like you
don't want more money
so
so we get there as soon as we get there
they say the line for Nintendo World is
virtual so we go sorry oh that's great
we don't have to wait in line
then it says
we try to do it on the app
no more slots available so I'm like
looks like this is gonna be a [__]
Harry Potter time right
I want to see Mario [__]
so
my wife's like oh [__] we can't do it oh
well I said there's enough Mario stuff
here where we could pretend we went he's
only three
you don't really know I hate the lie to
him but I'm not really lying it's just
like I want to show him a bunch of Mario
stuff I'll buy him a little star it'll
be fine we'll go to Hardee's and get a
wrapper I think it's a [__] Mario
star you know
and uh we'll drive by Carl's Jr oh there
it is Buddy okay let's go home
um and so
just [__] drive by the Carl's Junior
just
there it is Buddy
and um
buddy look outside
there it is
so um
maybe so sad when I would ever hear that
[__] and so what
so the other guy from Police Academy so
anyway
um
so I uh
went to Nintendo World
and couldn't get a slot great so now we
can get a slot but I go like this dude I
think about my dad
and I said what would my dad have done
in this situation and the thing that I
had come up with in my head which is the
truth is
my dad would have got into Nintendo
World no matter what
I know that about my dad
so in my head I'm like
my dad think he's better than me
I could do that
but it was a much different time back
then right in the 80s it was way easier
to sneak into places I mean you could do
anything in the 80s you could do
anything in the 80s you could walk down
the street with your dick all out and
punch everyone and not get caught
straight up ever
and now it's like if you even think
about it they're like this guy this
guy's looking Shady get him on camera
and you're like oh for oh [__] okay I'll
just I'll just be regular no punching
huh only thing I think I want to go to
the bathroom and all right so
and I know my dad would have got in but
I'm like but it's a different era but I
should be better than my dad at getting
into places and doing stuff that I want
to do for my kids because the students
are passions the teacher right that's
what we all hear the students got to
surpass the teacher right I'm looking
good with all the tattoos huh pretty
[__] sexy so um
so I I go like this you know what babe
uh I'll be right back
she says
well you know what I actually have the
stroller anyway William doesn't isn't
going to really experience that why
don't you go with Calvin and Jerica our
friend and we'll see if we can uh get in
and I say all right I'll see if I can
get in so I walk up
and I Look to our friend
and she says they're scanning and I go
yeah I see they're scanning
and I'm with Calvin and her and she says
we're [__] and I said we're not [__]
we're not [__] right because we'll be
[__] when we can't get in and right
now it's before that so there's always a
plan that we can have
so I woke up and I said you know what oh
[__] my my wife has it on her phone and
I don't have the thing with me uh I
don't have it downloaded and she says oh
where's your wife and I said she's
actually a few back but she had the
stroller
um can we just like wait for her here
off to the side she says sure just wait
over there points behind her and I go
I don't have eyes
and I'm very slippery
so I said okay cool
I wait for a little bit I got Calvin
I wait for the lady to turn her head but
I wait a little bit longer I'm not the
guy who goes that first jump because she
could be faking us out she could be like
yeah wait right there anyway
but she didn't she goes yeah wait wait
yeah all right boop boop boop three
scans she forgot about it you know why
I realized she doesn't give a [__]
right she just wanted us to make it easy
on her if we were gonna sneak in she was
basically saying hey please
don't let me see it
so I grabbed Calvin I say let's go we go
into the [__] thing and dude we're in
I got my son Calvin in to Nintendo Land
by being sneaky in 2023 so hey my dad
could have done that in the 80s but how
about them apples my dad
[Music]
anyway
crystallia sneaks into [__] Nintendo
Land
um
we get in dude and it's first of all
it's too crowded
right
too crowded
it's too hot
and it's too crowded
it's too loud
everybody there is ugly
shape up everyone huh
do squats everyone right now do squats
ten you know what I'm saying
anyway dude it's cool it's all good and
it's just like
but we were there bro they killed it it
looks nice right it looks real nice and
uh my son holy [__] he was just he loves
uh Bowser and the plants that come out
of the
tunnels and
uh whatever the warp the [__] tunnel
warps
and there were plenty of those
you didn't want to go to Bowser's Castle
because it looked a little bit scary
um we saw Mario and Luigi and he loved
he was just watching it and then do it
there was a line for getting a picture
with Marion Luther was insane then they
say oh Princess Peach is coming out
everyone I look over the line is out to
[__] it's like the line in Russia for
bread in 1982. and um
and so Princess Peach comes out in her
and the costumes they have now are like
legit it's not like just some like doofy
[__] like big ass like Philly fanatic
you know what I'm talking about 1995.
they the face of Princess Peach like her
mouth moves and her eyes are big and
they move and I'm like who's operating
this are there two people in there one
guy's sitting on another
I know
or is it a robot right so uh the line's
passing and I'm we're out of the line
I'm with Calvin I go look
oh and by the way Kristen somehow got in
with William I don't know how she got in
but she ended up getting in and um
no one heard she probably did it the
right way
um
and so Princess Peach
I don't know how to tell this
because there's so many people around
and also it's just a face that she's
it's not an actual person's face it's
the costume
and I'm like
she's [__] looking at me
like I I'm like she's [__] she is
looking at me right but I'm like ah
maybe my ego is a lot of control and
also how can I tell the [__]
mask you know it's not a real per like
her eyes are not real right so I'm like
maybe she's not looking at me right but
then she grabs the [__] worker guy
there the guy who is not dressed as
anything except for a worker you know
and she grabs him after taking pictures
with somebody and she said she's
like whispering in his [__] ear
or you're probably yelling nobody could
hear her right but like because there's
that whole thing over the speakers and
it's like I'm Princess Peach come to me
to take pictures and and Princess is
doing all the thing but really she's
actually saying something to this guy
I don't know if that's a recording or
someone else is doing it you know
and I'm like
[__] is talking about me
so now I got now I'm like I got do I
have beef
with Princess Peach
like do I actually have beef here at
Nintendo Land is she gonna [__] say
is she like whispering in the workers
you know that's that guy that got
canceled in 2020 the comedian
and I'm I'm like I don't know what she's
saying but I'm like here we go whatever
it is
it's not gonna be regular right
so
the [__] worker and I said it my
friend and I say to Kristen and they
[__] they're they're talking about me
and
the worker turns with his real face and
now looks at me
and points to me so I'm like Yo dude hey
we're all we're about to fight we all we
all we're gonna have to fight soon we're
gonna have to actually be Mario and
Luigi and fight these [__] Goombas
and Koopas
you know get ready start jumping on some
heads Calvin
like I'm like some [__] whatever's gonna
be happening it's not gonna be regular
right so
she's pointing at me he's pointing at me
she points
the [__] worker comes up to me and
says
hey
uh Princess Peach wants to meet you
like to me says
[Laughter]
just some dude in a blue and red worker
outfit says hey man Princess Peach wants
to meet you man
and I say oh uh
all right
I bring the family
we walk up to Princess Peach
she's just doing this
and I'm like I
this isn't really you're not I'm not
really meeting her like I don't
a man can be in there for all I have no
idea I have no idea I think it's a woman
I look at the arms I'm like this a woman
but I said oh thank you so much can we
get a picture and she's like yeah the
guy took the camera take a picture took
a professional picture boom boom he says
and I say to Princess Peach thank you so
much I really appreciate you doing that
and I felt kind of bad because she
obviously did it because you know she
recognized me and
I felt kind of bad because I cut the
line but then a lot of people in the
line were like hey crystalia let's take
a pic and I took a picture with them too
and it's like
so I don't I don't know maybe maybe some
people are mad but
it was nice uh and I got that picture
for and we got the picture here it's
right here
um of uh Kristen and uh me and Calvin
and uh William and Princess Peach so
whoever that was the Princess Peach
thank you I don't know who you are
um
but very very cool that you did that or
if it was just Zac Efron
um
but yes Super Nintendo land or Nintendo
Land I actually don't even I don't even
know what it's called but uh whatever it
is it's it's actually very cool
um if it was less crowded you could go
go not on a Saturday and go when it's
not so hot which is [__] hot now
I know it's hot
um
I told you that story right guys about
the [__] uh the pizza guy used to
work at La Canada Imports when we were
coming up in La Canada he was an old guy
and you you would go and get the pizzas
and orange bang and then the [__] his
Vietnamese wife would always be like
it's hot and then he would turn around
and heard him say all over under his
breath about his wife but I heard it and
she didn't he said I know it's [__]
hot
and I immediately thought wow wow nobody
I'll never forget that I'll never forget
that how about that how about them
applesauce I'll never forget that
um
oh
bro I found my new favorite guy
I found my new favorite guy for real
straight up
so first of all I'll tell you his name
afterwards
God damn it
that was so loud just cut it out huh cut
that part out I'll make it low the
[__] uh what do you call it the um
sorry about that the uh sound plant is
is the max volume is too low and so that
happened
uh we'll bleep that part this is my
favorite part he's in he's in
a coffee shop
or a cafe and he just starts
whaling dude
[Music]
foreign
the whole thing
[Music]
that's my favorite part of the song
dude imagine listening to the song be
like oh he's my favorite part
oh falling in love that woman
[Music]
all right guys killing it oh falling in
love all of them falling in deep love
like thinking about their like having
families with them
oh not done that's
[Applause]
screaming dude
wow that's so killer dude that guy this
guy's called the best sudden singer
that's like so funny sudden singer this
guy is
so awesome man I want to do this so bad
and I'm not that good at it
look at this guy look at this guy how he
does it killer [__] come on play it
it's cool how I can't do it I'll guess
you won um
I guess he won uh
what do you call it uh uh Germany Got
Talent
that's the most Italian thing to win by
the way Germany got talent talent going
going to Germany and just [__]
absolutely crushing it up
[Music]
I gotta do that come on Sudden singer I
gotta just go to the Coffee Bean and
just there we go this one
not that one
that was a really good one oh it was the
pizza one
what was the pizza one
or he just takes up
where's the pizza here it is here it is
this is the song
immediately everyone's happy
two gay guys kind of pissed off though
like I mean we saw
I've seen better
[Applause]
the guys dressed so like somebody from
La Canada
[Music]
so good
the slightest in the pizza like he
doesn't give a [__]
and then he buys the pizza the most
Italian thing of all time
[Music]
screaming
that's so awesome dude wow this is
something that's so awesome that if it
happened in real life I would be so
annoyed at dude
[Music]
I wonder if I did if people would clap
at the end for real dude
oh well that was bad
um oh I have to go in active alarmists
from a true baritone but uh yes he was a
tenor okay cool he's a tenor
uh all right that's it dude that guy
kills dude sudden singer
uh thank you very much for listening my
tour at chrisley.com Tucson I'll be in
Colorado Nashville Montreal all
different places
um that's it for the regular uh show if
you want the extra the uncut episode of
congratulations uh going on to patreon
patreon.com crystallia uh it shows much
longer and also there's that extra show
you get every month there's about 30 of
them there now you can go listen right
now or watch right now if you sign up
for only six bucks patreon.com chrislea
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you